هناك كاميرا واحدة على هذه السيارة في الأعلى
هنا وهي ترسل جميع
المعلومات والصور إلى الهاتف
الموجود هنا على لوحة القيادة
والهاتف يتخذ القرارات بشأن
المكان الذي يجب أن تذهب إليه السيارة ولكن أولاً يجب
أن يتعلم ما هو موجود في هذه الدورة التدريبية.
سنقلع بدء التعرف على الأشياء ، أضعه في
Drive ، لذا لا يزال البشر ضروريين إلى حد ما
، فأنا في عملية اكتشاف جسم التروس ، تم
تفعيل تهيئة سيارتك
، هل تضغط على محرك الأقراص وتستمتع بالرحلة ،
يا إلهي ، لا أعرف أبدًا ما أنا  عند الدخول
في هذه السيارات ذاتية القيادة ، نحن نقطع
مسافة ميل في الساعة ، لذا
فهم الآن يتحركون في مختلف العقبات
في المسار
الذي توقفت فيه السيارة للتو ، لذا قمنا بالجولة الأولى
حيث شعرت الكاميرا والهاتف
بذلك  مسار العوائق هذا ، لذلك
نحن الآن جاهزون بالفعل للقيام
بمسار العقبات ولكن لا يزال يتعين علينا أن يكون هناك
شخص ما هنا من أجل الأمان الآن يمكننا
القيادة للبحث عن صوت صاخب ، لقد
انطلق بسرعة ، ومن المفترض أن أوقف
ذلك بشدة.  ر توقف  pd بهذه السرعة
منذ أن كان عمري 16 عامًا أدرس للحصول على رخصة قيادتي